à voisins le bretonneux le premier tour
devrait voir s'affronter trois listes la
dernière à s'être déclarés avec vos
voisins avant second soir peut être
espira bonsoir meloni poker vous êtes la
tête de liste ou partie de cette liste
c'est votre première candidature à une
élection déjà pourquoi vous êtes lancé
en politique
alors j'ai aujourd'hui 50 ans je suis
salarié dans l'industrie sur saint
quentin en yvelines et j'ai pensé qu'il
était important avec mes compétences de
management de projets l'habitude de
gérer des budgets de faire aussi des
négociations surtout à l'international
de mettre ses compétences au service de
la municipalité au service des vies
sinoise et davy sinois pour apporter un
visage neuf et un regard neuf sur la
ville et pourquoi tête de liste pourquoi
tête de liste plus effectivement parce
que une première sur une liste est tout
de suite tête de liste beaucoup de
personnes me font la remarque c'est très
ambitieux nous parlons de démocratie
participative
nous avons fait un vote nous étions deux
anneaux candidater pour être tête de
liste et j'ai été choisi
peut-être que mon dynamisme a fait la
différence alors pour vous ce sont les
premiers pas dans la vie politique ce
n'est pas le cas de tous vos colistiers
et notamment jean achille est deuxième
derrière vous sur la liste élue depuis
25 ans sur la commune il est
actuellement conseiller municipal
d'opposition vous servez tout
l'expérience tout à fait bien sûr je ne
me serais pas engagé seul dans une
histoire aussi importantes pour la vie
municipale
j'ai dans l'équipe jean h en numéro 2
mais aussi geneviève tellier et
christophe page ou qui sont des élus
depuis quelques années et leurs examens
dans l'étonnant l'opposition
actuellement alors on parle plus de
minorités que d'opposition pour ce qu il
arrive aussi que nous soyons d'accord
avec les propositions faites en conseil
municipal donc opposition ça donne
l'impression qu'on est systématiquement
poser non on a nos propres idées notre
programme avec trois grands axes que
nous défendons une ville éco responsable
une ville citoyenne avec la démocratie
participative est aussi une ville
solidaire
alors laissez donc cela on va les
développer un petit peu plus tout à
l'heure je voudrais qu'on parle de la
liste de manière générale comment elle
s'est construite c'est plutôt une liste
orienté de centre gauche mais vous la
voulez non partisane tout à fait parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous nous sommes soutenus
par aucun parti
donc nous rassemblons des personnes qui
ont différents qui viennent de
différents horizons et nous nous
rassemblons autour de nos trois axes
comme je les dis à une ville éco
responsable une ville citoyenne est une
ville solidaire et justement pourquoi
ces trois axes alors parce que nous nous
retrouvons autour de ses piliers qui
pour nous sont des valeurs importantes
aujourd'hui une ville éco responsable
pourquoi parce que l'écologie est une
vraie préoccupation je suis moi-même
membres du bureau d'une amap association
pour le maintien de l'agriculture
paysanne
très investie dans cette association et
je pense que il est important de
s'occuper de la planète
nous voyons nous l'avons encore vu ce
week-end avec la tempête que nous
n'avons pas d'habitude vous êtes février
ça c'est le premier point la partie
ville citoyenne parce que nous pensons
qu'il faut aller plus loin et utiliser
beaucoup mieux les conseils de quartier
pour faire un lien est un réel vecteur
de communication entre les vies sinoise
et lévis sinois et la municipalité
justement de ce côté là vous proposer de
mettre en place une assemblée vie sinon
à ce qui serait composé de 30 personnes
elle serait en complément des conseils
de quartier nouvelle serait lé
remplacerait alors en complément des
conseils de quartier pourquoi parce que
la ville va avoir dans un bref avenir à
gérer des sujets très importants je
pense à la ligne 18 notamment qui va
entraîner des évolutions dans la ville
et nous avons besoin de prendre le recul
est de prendre des décisions
stratégiques pour intégrer au mieux ces
évolutions dans notre vie donc l'éco
quartier qui se construit actuellement
rentrer dans cette thématique
l'éco-quartier et déjà décidé donc
difficile de dire qu'on va l'étudier
puisque
décisions sont déjà prises mais toutes
les nouvelles décisions à prendre
devront être prises avec toujours je le
répète à nouveau nos trois piliers pour
avoir une stratégie globale et cohérente
alors on sait que l'un des enjeux
notamment des villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est la
circulation aux heures de pointe de la
ville est engorgé vous s'était notamment
que la rd 91 devienne un boulevard
urbain mêlant logements commerces
services activités économiques des
explications supplémentaires de ce alors
effectivement la circulation est un
sujet récurrent dans la ville de voisins
puisque voisins se trouve aussi portes
du parc naturel régional de chevreuse
donc en tant que porte bas il ya
beaucoup de voitures qui passent par la
porte notamment 600 véhicules heure aux
heures de pointe dans voisin sud
les solutions doivent être prises aussi
avec l'agglomération et aussi avec les
villes du parc naturel régional
imaginez qu'on ferme la ville serait
utopique donc il faut trouver des
solutions à nouveau un nous prônons la
démocratie participative et la
concertation avec les habitants pour
trouver des solutions et gilles de
pénalisation ni z apporteriez pour
réguler cette circulation nous dans
notre axe de solidarité nous pensons
aussi beaucoup aux transports collectifs
trouver des solutions notamment en
termes de transport collectif
interurbain pour délester les véhicules
qui arrivent de la vallée de chevreuse
et aussi à l'intérieur de la ville
réduire le trafic interne avec notamment
la mise en place d'un plan vélo et d'un
plan marche car souvent on ne se rend
pas compte que les distances
relativement courte et qu'on va parfois
beaucoup plus vite à pied ou en vélo
qu'en voiture
vous souhaitez aussi transformé voisin
de villages villes villages en ville
urbaine
mais ce que cela sous-entend pas plus de
construction et donc peut-être plus de
circulation voisin bordeaux ne fait
partie de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
dans ce sens il est intégré aux
évolutions de l'agglomération il ne faut
pas oublier que notre ville a quand même
perdu presque mille habitants durant les
dix dernières années un des classes
scolaires enfermé et il faut notamment
pour faire vivre les commerçants qui
vivent dans
ville avoir une attractivité et attirer
des jeunes familles pour attirer des
jeunes familles nous pensons qu'il est
important d'avoir un plan ambitieux
notamment à travers des outils de
logements solidaires je pense à
l'exemple de ce qui a été fait dans la
ville de rennes où on sépare le foncier
et du bâti pour réduire le prêt
d'accession à la propriété et ceci pour
permettre donc d'avoir d'attirer des
familles des jeunes familles aujourd'hui
ça l'a été dit pour montigny le
bretonneux et c'est le même sujet pour
voisins le bretonneux
le prix du mètre carré est un frein à
l'installation des jeunes familles dans
notre vie et peut-être du côté des
logements sociaux aussi on sait que
voisin n'atteint pas les 25% avec la
musette à 18 5%
c'est dans votre programme qu'il
construire des logements sociaux
alors effectivement les logements
sociaux nous avons une obligation légale
d'arriver à 25 % sinon il ya des des
contreparties financières qui sont
demandées donc il est clair que nous
étudions aussi la possibilité de faire
un effort de ce côté là qui s'intégrera
dans un plan global d'urbanisme qui sera
d'ailleurs un sujet qui sera traité lors
du débat planifier ce samedi 22 février
chez nous c'est notre place on arrive à
la fin de cet entretien béatrice pire as
qu' il y à des réunions de campagne
à noter pour ceux qui voudraient allez
vous rencontrer lors tout à fait nous
avons des réunions de campagne qui sont
indiqués sur notre site internet www
voisin avant ce point fr où toutes les
informations les dates les horaires et
des lieux sont indiqués merci est bien
triste spirale je le rappelle vous êtes
tête de liste de avec vos voisins avance
pour ces élections et sont également
candidats pour la commune deux voisins
le bretonneux la maire sortante
alexandrins rosetti et le conseiller
d'opposition olivier affonso